اوه مجددا لا تويتر والخبر اللي ما راح
تتفاجعه فيه لانه سمعنا مثله كثير السنه
الماضيه فيبدو انه الماسك ما اكتفى بطرد
3700 موظفين نوفمبر 2022 ولا وطبعا وهو مش
سائل ابدا بالانتقادات اللي بتعرض لها
بسبب هذا الموضوع اليوم نفذ جوله تسريح
جديده هاي المره شملت موظفين من مكاتب
الشركات في ايرلندا وفي سنغافوره من
العاملين في فريق الثقه والامان اللي
بيتعامل مع الاشراف على المحتوى العالمي
بالوحده المتعلقه بخطاب الكراهيه والتحرش
وفي تبرير للشركه لعمليات التسريح الجديده
قالت الى ايرن رئيسه القسم الثقه والامان
في تويتر في ايميل انه الالاف من بيعمله
ضمن فريق الثقه والامان على الاشراف على
المحتوى واللي بيقوموا بهذا العمل يوميا
وهدول ما طالتهم التسريحات اضافتهم بعض
تخفيضات العماله في مناطق تفتقر للع
الكافي المضيق قدما او حيث يكون من المنطق
ضمها لا مكاتب اخرى ومنبقى كمان في اخبار
تويتر ولكن هالمره في طرح مزايا جديده
اعلن عنها السيد تويتر الى ماسك واللي
اعلن في تغريده عن قرب طرح مجموعه من
الميزات الجديده اللي كثر الحديث عنها
مؤخرا الميزات الجديده بتضمن تنقل سريع
وسهل يمين ويسار ما بين التغريدات
المقترحه وتغريدات الحسابات المتابعه
والمميزه هاي منتظره لاحقا هذا الاسبوع
بالاضافه الى الجزء الاول من اصلاح شامل
لواجهه المستخدم ماسك اعلى كمان في
تغريدته عن زر بوك معقله تغريدات واللي
بتمكن المستخدم من حيث تغريدات معينه
بسهوله الرجوع اليها زر مثل اللايك يعني
بس
ما بين يعني بس ما بين سايلنت عند حدا اما
الميزه الاخيره فهي ميزه جدليه وعليها
كلام كثير وهي ميزت تغريدات الطويله وهذه
ماسك وعد فيها من اوائل فبراير